in this video for 3d geometry we will be
talking about two topics one is the
angle bisector of two planes and one is
line of intersection of two planes one
of the topics are important especially
in the line of intersection of two
planes and I will be spending some time
on that angle bisector of two planes is
a very easy topic just sort of like
something you have to remember while
you're preparing for Jay and I'll just
give you the formula I have won't even
be doing a problem on this but I will be
spending some time on this because I
think this is a very relatively
important topic okay so what is so let's
say we have a pair of plane and you have
to find an angle bisector so that
initially so this is the angle bisector
and a plane which is the angle bisector
of the two planes so this angle is the
same as this angle and you have two we
have been given equations for P 1 P 1
and P 2 and you have to find this
equation of what it would be like so now
if you think about this the way the
easiest way I think about planes is
actually thinking using a notebook so I
always recommend you can do that if you
are a little confused so now this is
let's say I have a plane like I have to
place like this again they are infinite
so let us say I have two planes like
this and then what angle bisector would
be something which is bisecting this
angle but this plane this plane is can
also be extended into this direction
here so it can there can also be an
angle bisector of this angle between the
two planes so there is all there are
always two angles one is the accurate
only this one is accurate and one is
obtuse
so you can find both of equations for
both of the planes and the way you do it
is very simple so I will just describe
how you find the equation of both kind
of planes okay so again there are two
angles obtuse and accurate how will you
find angles just take the dot product
with an n1 and n2
you get an angle either obtuse are acute
so one would be if there is another
angle when you subtract 180 minus that
to get the other angle all right so let
us now let us
we have equations like I mean this is
just the way it has been this is just
literally almost like remembering that
how you should do it so I am currently
writing b1 here so please take note of
this and generally I write
generally D on the right-hand side but
this time it is here and whenever you
get something like this and sure sure
b1 and b2 are greater than zero I'm
going to clearly write D 1 greater than
0 comma D 2 greater than 0 and ensure
this so whatever equation is take this
constant to the left-hand side and
something multiplied by- if you need is
to make this greater than 0 once you
have ensured that then check check if
even a 2 plus v1 v2 plus C 1 C 2 is
greater than 0 then check if even a 2
plus B 1 B 2 is greater than 0 if it is
greater than 0 then a 1 X plus B 1 Y Z
when Z minus B 1 by root of ay 1 square
plus B 1 square plus C 1 square is equal
to a 2 X plus B 2 y minus T 2 where root
of ay 2 square C 2 square will be the
this would be the angle but this will be
the angle bisector of the obtuse side up
to side and similarly the whole thing
let me just write it down so that there
is no confusion
there should be the angle for the acute
side okay so and with a negative sign in
front so this is only when a 1 a 2 plus
B 1 B 2 plus C 1 C 2 is greater than 0
and if it is not greater than 0 and vice
versa otherwise so the signs would
reverse if this is less than 0 so vice
versa if or I mean if it is not clear
probably why just say opposite if even a
2 plus B 1 B 2 ok think like this so
whatever the sign of a 1 a 2 plus B 1 B
2 plus C 1 C 2 would be that would be
the sign of the Optus side so that is
how you can remember that is how I
remember but you again have to ensure D
1 is greater than C don't it n 0 so it's
a very very it's not a query conceptual
thing I mean I can explain to you how
this equation was derived it's not hard
to see this is actually similar to what
you probably have already done in the
chapter of vectors where there is that
there was the discussion of angle
bisector of two angles but I mean that's
not the important point here the
important point here is to if it comes
and if you are being just remember this
thoroughly
it's literally like just being careful
with signs and calculation so I'm not
doing a problem and for this you can do
very easily construct two two planes and
then just find the angle another
Shepherd I think it's pretty
straightforward just you have to
remember the formula okay now let's go
to the next part which is a very
interesting part is the line of
intersection of two planes so
let us say you have two planes p1 and p2
so what is the angle what is the line of
intersection of the two planes that is
the line which is this line this is the
interaction of two line of intersection
of two planes so again if you have a
notebook then the way you think about it
is that if you have a notebook like this
then this line is the line of
intersection so it just take a notebook
and look at this line and this is your
line of intersection so how would you
find the equation of the line so if you
know p1 and p2 and the question would be
how would you find this line L here how
would you define this so what do we need
to define a line you need a parallel
vector so with p1 you will have one n
vector and one vector and n 2 vector and
now you need a point here a vector of a
point and you need a parallel vector
okay so what is the property of this
parallel vector the property is parallel
to that it lies on both it is parallel
to both p1 and p2 place right because it
it is parallel to the line and the line
is in both the planes so it is two
parallel to both plane p1 and works when
we do so in other words it is
perpendicular to both n1 and n2 and as
soon as I say this it should flash into
a mind that B vector that B vector is n1
cross and to be that there is n1 i mean
this is just something straight out of
the cross for a definition that be b
vector is equal to n1 cross and 2 and
please please please you should recall
the charter of vectors if you're
forgetting please always remember how to
do that so you first step you'll do is
you will do find n 1 Cross n 2 for B
vector and the second thing you will do
is find a common point find point by
putting one coordinate to be 0
one coordinate to zero so I will solve
the problem so that will hopefully make
it easier for you to so the equation for
p1 that has been given to you is X plus
y plus Z is equal to one so this is X
plus y plus Z is equal to one and the
other thing that the other plane is has
been given to you is X minus y plus Z is
equal to one okay
X minus y plus Z is equal to one so
first thing you have to do is we have to
find B vector so what is n1 vector that
is ICAP plus j k plus k cap and n2
vector is ICAP minus j cap plus k cap
now b vector would be i j k 1 1 1 1
minus 1 1 and you if you open this up it
will come to I cap
- I cap minus two K cap okay this is
what we get and you can check by taking
a dot with both of them this is 2 - 2 0
+ 2 - 2 0 so this is a vector that is
perpendicular to both N 1 and n 2 so
this is the vector parallel to the line
and then you have to find a point on the
line which is how to find so this was
step 1 the step 2 would be so we can put
any coordinate OB 0 let's put Z is equal
to 0 in both the planes so what we are
doing is we have to find a point so we
have to get the x coordinate y
coordinate at coordinate but there are
two equations and three variables so we
are putting one coordinate to be 0 so if
you put Z is equal to 0
then you just have two equations in two
variables and then you know the point
right so we have now X plus y is equal
to 1 and X minus y is equal to 1 so if
you that will give you X is equal to 1/2
and Y is equal to also 1/2 so sorry X
equal to 1 and Y is equal to 0 actually
so this will become X plus y equal to 1
and X minus y equal to 1 so this becomes
X equal to 1 comma Y is equal to 0 so
the point a is 1 comma 0 comma 0 so
equation of line L is actually I cap
plus lambda2 I cap minus 2 K cap okay so
this line would lie in both plane 1 and
plane 2 and you can also write it in the
coordinate form let us just write it in
the coordinate form also so X minus 1 by
2 is equal to Y minus 0 by 0 so that
means Y is equal to 0 so Y minus 0 by 0
is equal to Z by -2
okay so I hope that this made sense gave
you a good idea of what it means so line
of intersection like a notebook is a
line common to both the plains it is
perpendicular to both N and O so it has
to the parallel vector has to be an one
cross and in two and then you can find
the point where quoting when putting one
coordinate to be zero so this was the
topic for angle bisector of two planes
and line of intersection of two planes
the next video now we'll start mixing up
line and planes and points and planes
and things like that so I hope to see
you in the next video I hope you enjoyed
this video